when welcome to this video I hope you
all made it to today's live show and I
see some things are not quite right
I completely forgot to put up my green
screen oh my goodness but there came no
why you see all the books in the
background it's maybe a change that some
of you do welcome
yeah I was too busy figuring out the
technical details of my broadcast I'm on
my new computer and the other thing that
I just see us I have no background
layout let me let me check that that
that looks extremely weird okay now I
have some the wooden background layout
let's get going I hope you hear and see
me all right um let's go some five
minutes on the SSC I come if it's taught
everything in you I've got - a newly
installed and I have I have fun what
what are those pieces that is not what I
usually have so I really have to check
this again after the broadcast wow that
is a funny animation speed I have to
change that time that that route that
will drive me crazy yeah oh my god no
and I will change I will change that
real quickly
so let's do this and where's the
animation speed animation fast fast okay
this is a little bit more like I am used
to it so um what's going on here I have
to play the children I'm sorry it's the
thing that I know best this actually
looks a little bit different than what I
had the form okay something new doesn't
doesn't really hurt you feel like you're
in the 19th century why is that
oh okay
I have spent fifty seconds for this
yeah the set up is a little bit weird I
know but it'sit's all do you mind do to
my new comp yes and I had to reinstall
everything and so on I think the pieces
look quite okay right I think yeah I
think I like it I'm sorry that I forgot
to put up the green screen there were so
many other things that I needed to check
in fact I didn't expect this to happen
that I have to check so much but then
f-dotus
ah oh my god this is wrong and yeah so I
had to do some things and that took up
some time yeah I'm very happy with in
with a new computer it's so the main
thing that currently is taking time is
adjusting to to Windows to Windows 10 I
think
probably Windows 10 is okay yeah it's
just that if you're not used to it you
[Music]
yeah sometimes wonder about things like
where is exactly the setup and so on and
ya know I monster on sixteen gigabyte
RAM I was thinking about 32 but I
actually on my old machine I had eight
and I didn't really experience any
issues so sixteen felt okay and I can
easily get to 32 ever like I just have
to open it up and put two modules in and
I've got 32 so if I feel I need this I
can easily upgrade it it's a very
upgradable machine it's a noble thing
but so it is very much possible to
upgrade okay so in the game George has
played f4 this is a pretty standard idea
trying to open this up on the center he
played this route to a6 this is not so
clear to me what it does I'm going to
okay I'm really ok with the trades here
maybe he goes rugae five no he doesn't
Jim here you can actually think about
this yet occupying the a file that is
very rare in this opening that you can
occupy this an idea that I also have I
know I can trade Queens I'm really ok
with the training Queens in this
position he would probably not take
himself no he goes back
I'm really ok with the trading Queens
him let's see um how do we play he will
probably play rook a1 in order to trade
trade this as well I'm going to go here
you know and now to age six so that his
Bishop is not coming to c1 all that
easily don't see a drawback to this and
now a knight only five looks good but
it's not so clear what it what my plan
is so the next step that's same it is
not very threatening what setup but it's
also tough to improve my position so
Knight f5 is what he tries to do maybe
it's not another big threat actually I
can I can do this
I thought that I had to do this but yeah
how do i improve my position yeah here I
will take he has to take with the king
[Music]
and the next night now to next Knight to
e5 but it's not so easy to get there try
and wear a 8b 6075 it's a long long way
it seems he wants to go h4 hmm so maybe
I have to get out of the check let's get
out of the check
yeah that's the only way to lose this
game yeah blunder and one mover when
White was just moving around without any
particular idea yeah that's that's
really stupid yeah it was extremely
stupid it was a position where I didn't
have any problem at all
okay so how does he win this now that
looks like not so easy
so what's now
what's now
it's probably not possible to win this
position
mmm nice - I screwed that up royally and
in such an unnecessary way really
okay there was one of the most
unnecessary losses really I didn't know
what I do did here maybe I was I was
already getting ambitious of course
which I shouldn't be this is just not
good so not good anyhow let's go for the
next game I mean I was kind of the bit
distracted I like Eddie Messala great
great great great
this guy with no over the board rating
was like 2700 him so let's see what he
does he's got 2,300 over the water no
writing is wrong but he was 2700 in
blitz that was a bit bit high no I have
this the the webcam is the same but it
is different I don't I don't really know
you know some things have changed here
somehow yeah having this maybe Windows
10 makes a difference I don't really
know I know the webcam looks better
[Music]
okay
it might be yeah I didn't change
anything with the light yeah I really
didn't it's the same it's the same thing
yeah maybe without the chroma key M
that's possible
crispy amines more crunchy
so let's see I mean this is a rather
simple position
it is roughly equal the only thing that
my position is going for it is that I'm
a little bit his King side is a little
bit weakened with their five
so we push the a pawn not quite sure if
this helps him think it'd rather be
canned black it might not be a big deal
though
some ideas to push Seafire to open up
the whole thing okay can take check me
so put this to G true
so I'm going to take which is not so
easy easy decision but pond takes I just
I'm quicker on the D file they offered
me a draw but I don't like to make a
draw here I'm just better so ya c5
doesn't doesn't really help all that
much
mmm okay five and then see five maybe
I wonder about ya c5 now hmm it doesn't
really help all that much
doesn't help I wonder if I can play with
Eve or maybe maybe this interesting idea
listen Danny for for then G for I mean I
didn't see that move but I have checked
fortunately I didn't see it I really
didn't see it which is kind of
embarrassing
I would be a funny way to do a trap trap
your own rook like that and but possible
Rock d5 I don't believe so much that the
a pawn will be dangerous if he takes him
maybe it is
so maybe it is
threatening mate
keropi to enter seem to be lost all of a
sudden Joe I don't know I never
understand the games against this person
they are totally weird anyhow let's go
for the next game I never understand any
of the games that I play against him so
what about this one playing Super Puma
let's go in for see what happens okay I
hear this is getting into fashion
nowadays this Knight f6 and white tries
to play Queen e2 here crack that often
no I didn't work too much I'm just sick
of playing people with fishy accounts
it's just what it is and I'm tired of
thinking that I mean this is just anyway
let's not get them I never believed that
this is a valid account it's just what
it is
this person plays complete rubbish moves
and then all of a sudden plays like
Izzie ginge like genius and I don't
believe that it just doesn't happen
anyhow let's continue here and see if we
what we can do in this game Super Puma I
played in a bit of a weird fashion
I made me queen g4 I'm trying to try to
trade Queens now game let's play a solid
game here I can push the knight could
put the bishop here right
trying to pressurize him him I don't
know maybe 95 you know it's it's a it's
a little something that I have here but
not much
yeah it's it's probably probably roughly
equal here it looks like his quicker on
the D file but I can easily contest that
and I've got more space
okay so what's going on here if I take I
have the slightly slightly better
structure but of course black is very
very okay so just look the one next he
will probably just plonk the bishop on
to deform and it's a little bit lame to
trade I think I'd rather bring the King
to reform okay
let's prevent b5
I wonder if he if he attends to to play
no rooks III I was thinking could be his
intention but he didn't do that okay so
how to continue them h3g for maybe yeah
it's not it's not anything substantial
yeah really not okay I have a very small
edge iam very small he's got he's got
the slightly worse per instruction
should not be a big deal
oh that's surprising why did you take
now I get the H pawn whoa
I know you offered me a draw I don't
think this is this could be a bit too
late
it's not super easy actually push ahead
and then the bishop say that probably
wins
Bishop to f6 and then h5 I was thinking
I think that should win
okay so h5i will win the peace hmm
I just wonder if I have something easier
to do if they don't think so so let's
promote
King bee 685 I still still have to do
this correctly but this bishop is
covering a 1 and 85 so I think I can
just approach the opponent win the H
pawn and win yet Super Puma resides it
was a draw all along the way but taking
on g4 was a questionable decision
probably it was just wrong
ok let's see if we can get get a new
game ok kill Leon that's a really
regular opponent and I don't know can we
try no he plays the Italian game I don't
want to go in 5 it's a bit that he will
torture me for ages in the Italian so ok
interesting
so we have a closed a closed position
here out of the Vienna again
nighty - I have yeah exactly
h5 is an interesting move now but he has
Knight f3 is so on the other hand I mean
have a good control over d5 so maybe I
can just play d5 now I would say at age
5 I could have played h5 in this
position
what is he doing doing here
he will go g5 night h7 what is the deal
h4 Bishop g4 don't not quite sure what
is what the ideas maybe I should play
Bishop g4 earlier okay and now go for
long
hmm tough that's a tough position I
think it will go Bishop age three and
maybe he's better due to their foul
probably is he probably is
I have 98 to cover it
yeah white is white is better I think
I mean he has to coverage for some it's
not entirely one-sided
Scot g45 and he will definitely go for
that is always super ambitious and tries
to do stuff
hmm lady said I could be a threat I mean
not not now but King D 7
it was my what's the move I wanted to
play
yeah there are players that have been
wrong for ages on the ICC Kirlian this
is around for a long time for example
but I've also played people like not
what's the name Nadia good of course but
that was not the person that I was
thinking of so some some around for a
very long time I would absolutely like
to trade off that that night only way
would be from a 7 don't see how I get
down
simply no way
see 596 and so on I don't know where
he's headed with this I think he just
wants to move the night back maybe
see five looks a bit questionable
because I we can derive but he does not
have an easy route down towards the
clock I have the sound of him now John
the follow me wasn't around when I
started on ISS he was just too young
so we're 97 I did I'm not threatening to
take it's the problem
I don't know if this works but I don't
want to sit the whole time it doesn't
work oh my god oh my great
yeah I could resign but together I don't
like to
why should Killian be my nemesis I have
a + Co against him yeah rooster move has
been on for ages yeah that's true you
know now I can resign him yeah because
the well-played game I think but kyani
always had pressure i wonder am i wonder
i probably this h5 wasn't a good a good
idea at the end we look at this probably
I shouldn't have done that
like the h5 just play something normal
like 1976 or so I mean strategically
speaking this is quite dubious what he
did yeah h5 was a bad move ready it's a
really bad move that was a bad choice
you know it's dark weak on the dark
squares an H 5 H 5 is stupid it's just a
stupid move okay okay okay okay
playing dr. mabuse's let's go b6
let's check it out the heck are all of
it let's see you can probably play many
things and such in such a position
yeah and I know it's a little bit odd
yeah having different pieces but it
really does not yeah it shouldn't be a
big deal 96 of course I'm playing crap
really
I'm sorry sorry for the for the harsh
language but of course I have to prevent
deform I think I think what I did take
it only three was okay in that game
against them in the game perform against
Kellyanne but I think I shouldn't have
played h5 that was the main the main
problem
I hate this I just why not just knight
c6 and I'm totally okay no I just forgot
the green screen because I was too busy
with other stuff yeah I had to play
knight c6 and yeah but I forgot about
that
this position absolutely absolutely
sucks that is just a very bad maroc C
point
yeah nine th six really f3 okay
yeah the night is a funny piece I agree
try to play Knight Queen to c5 yeah f5
feels very risky really
and he will go king edge one
also have to have to add that I know the
white player is a former teammate of
mine and it's kind of this is like the
worst possible position you can have
against him he's really good at grinding
those kind of positions you're really
good
I hope I just hope that I'm not losing
out right yeah that that is the first
thing and it could be I mean it's very
much possible stuff like that
it's about 2,300 what the correct
position what a sad chess game beryllium
and it was just an extremely bad
position
never night on aged six seven yeah I
know I know that II five yeah but what
exactly you suggest to do I was trying
to take on d5 and not have a completely
completely busted porn structure
the only very very small hope is Knight
f6 to Knight f6 to h5 no my bishop is
attacked and e5 is also a checked
great
hey it's okay lost what can you do
rookie sixes
knock him it's not the clearest way and
made many things win roopd age is
probably his idea simply trading which
is enough
I don't even have an idea queen - f - if
he moves the Queen but who would do that
if I hmm really
it's still winning not quite sure why
you played f4 but probably but he's
getting no on time all of a sudden I
just offered me a draw no trough is very
very replay here no that's not mega draw
it's not easy for white I swindled him
why I completely swindled him or he
swindled himself whoa
that was absolutely atrocious Aaron what
I did
the main problem here was just just to
point out there with what what I made
what I what was my mistake here the
night on aged six it looks bad I know
but if I go knight c6 and prevent him
from playing D form I can go castles and
play a five that's actually quite okay
it has been played by Grandmaster kangas
for example from Latvia and it's it's
it's okay it's fairly fairly okay but it
was just like not thinking and allowed
him to play the form so I should have
played 96 ok playing a Hoffman here on a
Honda Hoffman I think GM Oh Phil it was
this is a pretty decent opening actually
G 3 is a good line D 5 is complicated
against ed but he didn't play it ok so I
don't exactly know how white plays this
I wonder if I had this on the board
against him oh I actually didn't
recognize that it was my my move again I
have the sound off which is a little bit
irritating
would it plays d4 before Ephraim sorry
Marcus I don't quite understand what
position you refer to in the standard
for the door you don't get the setup
with 97 or that easily or not at all
which you can do in in the neo leaders
okay especially chief I open it yeah I
mean the Knight has no squares you were
probably just dropped back okay so let's
centralize
maybe night f5
it's a tough position here a tough
position to play oh I did not really
watch the European Team Championships
it's a good question what teams did well
disappoint and so on I did not really
follow the event
that gets tricky now
very very tricky position he gets to e5
but I've got lots of space okay so he
plays for the dark squares yeah this is
an interesting strategy let's see if I
go Knight f3 see what is he doing Knight
see for me Leo I don't want to take
actually
let's keep that he does not want to play
Bishop e7 anyway so I don't mind
like OD 5v and an-94 it's an interesting
way of playing let's try that
now 94 ISM and an idea trying to win
this piece and now the exchange is
hanging ok Knight f6 here takes takes
the dark squares look extremely weak I
can also play Knight d6 just trying to
win material but TKE will very likely I
should start with this probably I forgot
actually that he's got 95 ok Knight f6
takes takes Queen c5 you might wind us
it's really it's really a bit funny
maybe 96 the rook has some real problems
there f6 he has to go Bishop age 8 but
maybe this threatening threatening FC so
that's actually stronger
and now Queen here right that looks
quite convincing I hope so where's the
mate where is the mate
Knight a5 no Knight g5 huh I'm 94 I mean
he's got exactly one check and that's it
I have 18 seconds left but his check
made and he resigned whoo okay so let's
go for one more game and see what
happens
I'm on yes I keep I kept my rating which
is okay
considering that played some pretty
stupid stuff and gave away some some
things so say I go on Wow okay we get in
Benko like at least it's going to be
something enterprising Bishop g5 now is
the main move this is not bad doorway
form
I wonder I wonder how that what the
justification of all this is because I
remember that it is okay for me but I
don't really remember why it looks
really wacky with the Queen on d6 but
maybe I can sneak to have form
[Music]
why didn't I go to g7 I think this is
this would have been a lot more a lot a
lot better
I think you forgot to take on d5 okay
I try to just go d6 97 finally trying to
develop something but widest is quite
substantially better here not sure about
this move now Queen e2 I mean I don't
quite know what it is doing
I'm not saying it's terrible I just
don't understand it and white is better
anyway Anna Bishop a three night age for
pressurizing a six it's the thing
so what to do what to do I think
[Music]
Wow I can't bring myself to play Bishop
a6
I mean I cannot cancel short iam
and this also looks weird maybe three
okay not quite sure where this is going
hmm is this is this so terrible
ah a blunder a blunder one mover this
was the idea it was just a one-off idea
great great and it was a bad position
anyhow I guess but this is of course
making it very easy for white I take his
got d6
[Applause]
would have begged him for it him this
has totally lost him and my good
I can play even take sandy five know if
he takes I can actually take take c5
which is still probably bad but
is there any any any any way to make
something happen here you're just like
completely without any play you know I
have no counter play whatsoever because
5 next I came out in a ticket this is
this is also lost em but I mean
Wow yeah I don't really want to do
comment much on the discussion about
chess service but I definitely have to
agree that play chess is the absolute
worst I mean really the people who are
acting that administrators this is a
disgrace really they managed to - yeah
insult me so much that I quit there
completely and just I mean I just had a
completely normal question and I mean I
got really completely insulted by the
admins that was extremely extremely
weird
I mean this is of course completely lost
but somehow I'm still still making moves
and I don't I don't quite know why every
time I am making moves
okay
that doesn't work Queen to b6 is made
yeah
Quincy was also made now let's play for
with with made okay play until made yeah
that was a bit rough him but he played
in a nice way
I am yeah I miss Knight takes e5 but I
think I really I have to quickly check
this which just quickly I mean I have
some knowledge about all this so what
what exactly went wrong night welcome
ninety-four here what was the deal
this is this is a bit strange already
really wonder huh I don't quite remember
really do I go Knight you for me instead
how do you play that this is kind of
okay for black but I completely miss
played that anyhow I'm glad you were
participating in the chat as much as you
did it's always good to have some
discussion they're going on thanks for
watching the show I hope to be back next
week next Monday as on the regular time
thanks for watching bye bye